okay
welcome to another episode of uh
q a about history of science and
technology
and uh i'm uh i'm happy to talk about
both things that have happened in my
lifetime that i
have direct personal knowledge of and
things that i might know
from historical research that i've done
so there are a few questions that i see
that have been saved up here
from last time 32 bits of robusts
asked any questions any stories about
your work
for thinking machines corporation
well sure i can try and tell some
stories about that so
first of all what was thinking machines
cooperation was a company based in
boston
that made an early kind of massively
parallel
supercomputer-like thing um in the
early to mid 1980s and uh
i got involved with thinking machines so
so thinking machines as a company
was uh its technical founder a person
called danny hillis
um who had been a student of marvin
minsky who was a kind of
ai pioneer at mit who i knew fairly well
who died a few years ago
marvin had many ideas about the way that
one could get things to think
and he had ideas about kind of the way
brains worked it's sort of funny because
he started his career uh marvin did back
in the 1950s
he was a graduate student at princeton
he did a math phd there
but his his one of his earliest
interests was in neural networks
uh neural networks were pretty young at
the time the mcculloch and pitts had
kind of
originally suggested kind of the the
sort of mathematical idealization of
neural nets in the 1940s
and uh marvin was interested in kind of
applying mathematical methods
to understand how neural nets worked he
also was kind of
enough of a tinkerer that he had
actually built uh physical
uh pieces of electronics i think he had
a thing called the snark if i remember
correctly which was a
kind of a physical 102 neuron neural net
thing so he's very into that stuff
um but then he kind of got very
disenchanted with it
after the 1950s going heading to the
1960s
he ended up writing a book called
perceptrons with seymour papert which
was kind of a
mathematical analysis of particular kind
of neural network
very simple neural network and kind of
showing that mathematically
those neural networks were too trivial
to do anything interesting
that became sort of a reason why people
didn't use neural nets
marvin i think was a little disappointed
by that because his book was only about
a very specific kind of neural nets
that didn't turn out to be the kind that
ended up working in the whole sort of
deep learning story
that came much later but in any case uh
marvin then
uh this is where we're now talking about
you know pre-history of thinking
machines but marvin
in the um uh late 50s early 60s got very
interested in kind of the formal theory
of computation
ended up writing an influential book
called um
i think computation in finite and
infinite machines
that was kind of a discussion of finite
automata turing machines
other kinds of simple models of
computation actually
as it happens i i literally just got
that book down off my shelf
last night because it's relevant to uh
the history of a project that i'm
working on right now
that has to do with a person called emel
post and these things called post
tag systems and marvin uh did some work
on that in 1961.
i could talk about that another another
time but in any case
so marvin got very involved in kind of
this formal uh
kind of analysis of computational
systems but
then was involved in the startup of the
ai lab
at mit uh in the early 60s when when
there was a lot of government funding
for ai and so on
and uh got more into the kind of
the kind of well how should we think
about thinking
in a more kind of holistic way not
in this kind of mathematical very
structured very formal kind of way
and uh worked on all kinds of things and
worked on all kinds of models for how
thinking must work
and i think in the late years of his
life um uh
when i talked to marvin it's like how
should one think about how you're
thinking about thinking so to speak
and uh i think he he viewed it more as a
kind of
a uh some of his theories more as kind
of meta theories in the sense of people
like freud
than they were sort of mathematical
theories in the sense of something like
turing
um but any case there was sort of an
intermediate period where he had these
ideas about
frames and this and that and and ways of
sort of thinking about thinking so one
of his ideas was
that sort of a key notion of thinking is
about
sort of having facts and making
connections between them
that it's all kind of about uh that that
one can have a sort of meta theory of
thinking
that is about sort of the notion of
representing knowledge and facts and
thinking about facts as all about
connections between things
so that was sort of a theory of ai so
uh one of marvin's students danny hillis
got got interested in well what if we
actually built
a thing that implemented that theory
could we make
an ai by by kind of setting up
the um uh the the the the system
so that um uh the um uh
uh so that one actually had built in a
machine
something that implemented this kind of
connection theory
of how thinking might work so that was
um beginning of the 1980s and um kind of
the notion was
let's make it so that um uh the uh
um uh you know what how would you make a
machine that is all about making
connections between things
well you need a machine that has lots of
separate processes
and where you're able to send
information between these different
processes
so that turned into this notion of let's
make this a massively parallel machine
that had lots of separate computer
processors
that are able to communicate with each
other now there have been a bunch of
history
to parallel machines the most common
kind of parallel machine was
a uh single instruction multiple data
machine
where where there was where you were
taking
one set of computer instructions it's
just feeding them out
to this large number of different
processors
which might have different pieces of
data like they might be analyzing
different parts of an image or different
pieces of some
some big graph or something but they
were all doing the same thing kind of in
lockstep
and they've been a bunch of machines
built for that purpose one of the um
uh well let's see there was one called
the iliac iv built at
university of illinois that was kind of
part of the kind of one of the late
stages of a kind of line of very
distinguished computers built at
university of illinois um
starting in the 1950s um and then there
was another one called the mpp
what was that the massively parallel
processor i think that was a nasa
project
there have been a variety of these kind
of single instruction stream
many uh you know all the separate data
kinds of machines the idea of the
connection machine was something more
ambitious
it was have all these processors
thousands and thousands of them
and be able to have uh
separate um separate uh operations go on
at the each processor
so the notion was let's have uh sixteen
thousand
sixty four 000 you know processors
and let's connect them and uh
the the the sort of hardware connection
was there's a hypercube a 16-dimensional
hypercube
um where each processor was
connected in 16 dimensions so to speak
or conceptually in 16 dimensions
to other processors but then the real
sort of uh
wonderful thing was supposed to be that
you could take
a piece of data at one processor and
route it immediately to any other
processor um
so that you could sort of implement this
idea of marvin's of sort of
connecting things together and
representing things using these kinds of
connections
okay so that was the that was kind of
the goal
and uh there was a question of sort of
how would this actually get built how
would it get set up
well the uh to
that that quickly turned into let's make
special purpose processors that might be
each individual processor might not be
able to do very much
but together they would somehow be able
to do lots of big things
so i guess i got involved in this um
oh when was it i i suppose some danny
came to a
conference that i organized at los
alamos about cellular automata in 1983
and i think he was just starting to
really work on thinking machines at that
time um and i somehow got involved as a
consultant to the company
the ceo of the company is a woman called
sheryl handler
who had um
previously done a company called
genetics institute which was kind of a
a sort of high intellectual value uh
kind of
scientists come in and build something
that was of commercial value um and um
she was sort of the the organizer of the
whole thing
they um they had a very charming um
i always think startups work
particularly well
when they have a sort of uh um
an interesting kind of physical presence
at the beginning and they
they had rented a house i think it's
called the thomas payne house it was a
kind of a
a country house type thing in waltham
massachusetts
um and uh they'd rented this kind of
sort of old house with grounds and and
it had um
uh you know all wood paneling everywhere
and all this kind of thing
was wood paneling uh and then there were
cables snaked all over the place and
that was a
very dynamic um environment um in which
to have a startup
um but in any case they had also
particularly i think cheryl
had um had started recruiting sort of
interesting characters
to be involved with the company another
interesting character who got recruited
was
uh was richard feynman dick fineman
physicist who i knew quite well
um his son carl feinman who had been a
student at mit
and had kind of known the sort of gaggle
of people um also
started working there in fact carl still
works with cheryl many many years later
in a different company
um uh carl had i think um
uh notably had insisted that his major
at mit will be philosophy because that
was something that dick fineman was like
i don't believe in philosophy
um such as the way of children um
but uh uh there were the the fineman's
uh another person who was involved very
early on who just graduated from mit was
brewster kale
who's gone on to do the internet archive
as well as several other companies
um and uh uh with a bunch of different
um interesting interesting people um
from different places sort of collected
together for this company another person
was uh
wasn't called dick clayton who'd worked
at digital equipment corporation
um as a hardware hardware developer
there
i mean back in those days uh digital was
the world's second largest computer
company the largest being ibm
uh digital equipment um uh was was the
second largest they made the
the pdp series of computers and then the
virtual address instruction the vax
computers
um they were uh very successful company
i was i was sad in recent times that
their headquarters was in
maine and massachusetts they were a
company that for various reasons had
these
had these different i suppose they had a
distributed approach to work
long before other people had distributed
approach to work but their distributed
approach to work
was to have these different um
facilities dotted around mostly
massachusetts and new hampshire i think
and um their kind of uh particular
feature was they had a fleet of
helicopters
that would take people between these
different uh facilities which was kind
of
exotic but their headquarters was in
maine and massachusetts and this mill
converted mill in maine of massachusetts
and they had a big factory in maynard
and a few years ago unfortunately as
digital digital failed eventually
as a company um and uh
the um uh they demolished this big
factory so it was kind of a sad thing to
see
i do have to tell i i'm i'm a little bit
segwaying from the original topic but
i do have to tell a story about digital
that was told to me by
um uh by ed fredkin actually who's a a
longtime sort of fixture on the
mit um uh and ai
ish scene and and also long-term
enthusiasts of cellular automata
ed tells many stories um some of which
i've been able to verify
um this is a story he told about digital
equipment corporation
um the uh uh one of the things that went
really wrong with digital
was they didn't get involved in personal
computers and um
um the um they have been involved in
and really you know ibm had made these
big mainframe computers
digital came along and made what they
called mini computers which were still
really physically huge but they were a
lot smaller and cheaper
than the things that ibm was making and
that was how they got started in the pdp
series of computers and then up to the
pdp 11 and so on
and then off after the vax and such like
but um when personal computers were
coming in there was a question should
they get involved
so apparently um uh
oh my gosh how can i have forgotten the
name of the ceo
um oh dear
well anyway that their ceo at the time
who had been their ceo um
um my gosh
slipped my mind um in any case the the
um
uh you know in the boston area that had
been uh the digital was a boston-based
company
you know had digital been sort of the
the long-term winner in the computer
business probably would have
would have tipped the balance somewhat
between east coast and west coast in
terms of
the energy around and around the
computer business i mean boston had
originally
been the site of wang labs
um which had been the first word
processing company
um and uh um
[Music]
the uh uh
so um uh
uh and that had sort of uh then digital
was sort of the next
big boston-based company anyway the
story as told to me by ed
um is that at the the key moment they
were thinking at digital whether whether
they should um
uh get involved with personal computers
or not so they did a focus group
and they got a bunch of people you know
every day you know people from all kinds
of walks of life
and they said you know what would you do
with a personal computer a personal
computer is going to be useful and a
good thing
apparently there was one teacher there
who was
one of the most enthusiastic people in
the focus group and who was talking
about
how wonderful uh computers uh personal
computers would be how important they'd
be to everybody
et cetera et cetera et cetera and um the
ceo
of digital was there listening to this
and was sort of almost getting convinced
yes these people are really enthusiastic
personally this is going to be a great
thing
and at the end of the focus group this
this teacher was like um
you know giving the speech about how
wonderful personal computers were
and he just wanted to add one more thing
at the end of the speech
and one more thing that he added was and
i don't just mean
here on earth and unfortunately
the claim was that was the moment at
which uh the then
uh ceo of digital said ah this personal
computer thing
it's all nonsense it's just a bunch of
loonies uh talking about some
uh talking about these things you know
uh let's just
stick to our main business of making
mini computers and so on
and that was a a bad business decision
but back to
thinking machines corporation so um uh
dick clayton was sort of the hardware
guy he'd come from digital
um the uh they kind of set about the
the task of building these um um
uh uh these these these
uh this computer and um
uh it was some there were a lot of
um kind of um well i was involved in
this in various ways i
i think um um i was not involved in any
of things like hardware design and so on
i was somewhat involved in the
architectural architectural questions
about how the computer would work
um the question one of the key questions
was
when you want to send a message from
here to there how would that work
and so it's like we have a processor
it's at this coordinate
in the 16-dimensional hypercube it wants
to send a message to this processor at
this coordinate
what will happen so they were very proud
of the idea that you could just sort of
give
the the message the relative coordinates
of those different processes and as the
message sort of
snaked its way through this hypercube it
would always sort of decrement
the direction that it had gone in and
say i have less
you know less distance to go in that
direction etc etc etc
until it got to its destination the
problem was what happened
when multiple messages wound up on the
same processor
and uh how would that work because there
was a certain buffer
that allowed you to have a certain
number of messages queued up but if that
buffer overflowed
then things would back up and messages
wouldn't be able to get delivered there
and it would all be a big mess
so one of the questions that i do get
somewhat involved in is this question
about
sort of what was the right algorithm for
transmitting messages but from from one
processor to another
i hadn't been involved in the in the
sort of original development of that but
but later on
it seemed like there was a problem with
this because one could do a calculation
that said if you were routing messages
around completely randomly
then things would be fine similarly if
you were routing messages around
in the way that you would for some
algorithms where there was a very
structured exchange of information
like in doing a fast fourier transform
or something like that you'd be fine
but the question was what would happen
when it was more random
and it was a case where actually i think
um
dick feynman had got this argument based
on statistical physics
for why it was going to be okay to have
a limited
size of buffer on these various
processors because messages wouldn't
queue up too much
and there was a young graduate student
who had
run these simulations and she was like
no this isn't going to work
there's going to be this tale of message
delivery and it was like
well you know dick fineman's worked out
that there isn't going to be and i was
like
i think the simulation is more likely to
be correct
than this analytical uh you know
calculation but well as it turned out it
was sort of too late
because these particular decisions had
already been burnt into the hardware of
the computer
um and there were custom chips that have
been built and so on
so it was kind of a too late type
situation but that turned out to be
actually quite a problem in the end that
that
for many kinds of actual ways of routing
messages around the computer
there was a sort of long tail of
messages that hadn't yet been delivered
because they got queued up and backed up
in these kind of message traffic jams
and so on inside the computer
but um i would say that let's see in
terms of the sort of
origination of the the company and so on
they um
uh i'm it's been a it's been a it's been
a while so i don't remember the complete
exact history of the whole thing but but
um
somehow i i was involved in the
discussion about the name of the company
and um uh i don't remember
um exactly how this went down but there
had been a company
that i'd known in england uh called
research machines that i thought was a
cool name for a company
that company still exists it went into
kind of educational computing and so on
wasn't its origin but um uh somehow i
was
was um involved in either suggesting or
supporting this idea of
thinking machines as a name for this
company that was building
this kind of machine that was going to
do this kind of ai
thing and that somehow got transmuted uh
into
international thinking machines was it
was a possible name
and the kind of the concept was just
like ibm
had originally been international
business machines that they would be
sort of the international thinking
machines and that was kind of an
aspiration
in the ibm direction it was also sort of
amusing that tom watson at ibm
was fond of uh having these signs up for
his employees
that said think and so the the the joke
at thinking machines was if it was
called international
international business machines had had
these signs that said think
put up for their employees so
international thinking machines
would have a sign put up for its
employees that said business
it was an idea never never really got
implemented
but in any case then then um
the i suppose my biggest contribution
probably
to thinking machines corporation was um
a day i don't know when it was probably
can be looked up
um uh when danny and i
were i was in boston and we went to see
this movie together it was a movie
called war games
which was kind of an early computer
hacker movie
about how a young i think the actor was
matthew broderick
um sort of breaks into this computer
that's the strategic air command's
computer and
is about to start world war three and
there's a there's a character in the
movie actually who
ed fred can came claims is based after
him
who's some strange guy who lives on an
island and has a has an
or has an autonomous pterodactyl
uh and so on but in any case this
movie and uh but one of the sort of
centerpieces of this movie is a computer
i think it's called the whopper computer
that um is a computer that's supposed to
be the you know the thing that controls
the defense the united states or
whatever
and its big feature is it's covered in
flashing lights
okay so we see this movie we're walking
out of this movie and i kind of
for some reason i still remember this
moment um and i i turn to danny and i
say
maybe your computer should have flashing
lights
and well turns out the connection
machine computer which is what thinking
machines built
that was this big it ended up having a
lot of red flashing lights
actually the industrial design of the
connection machine computer
it's a very nice industrial design it
looks a bit late it's a it's a
cubicle thing it looks a bit bit like a
rubik's cube has these uh
different sort of sub-cubicle segments
um kind of reflecting
in some way it's kind of hypercubic
structure there's a young designer
to mikko thiel i think is her name who
is sort of a
sculptor artist type person who did the
industrial design
for the computer and it was a was a very
striking industrial design a real
you know a big black cube i mean the
thing stood about as tall as a person
as a as this big black cube but the
thing that really made it
in the end was the fact that it was that
inside this big black cube it was
translucent um
plastic stuff on the outside were a big
array of red flashing lights
um and i think that was my contribution
uh so far as i know and so the um
so when when a connection machine
computer was running uh you know
covered with flashing lights i i have
sometimes said that the connection
machine
was the world's most successful direct
to museum computer
because if nothing else happened with it
um even if it was not
very successfully used as an actual
computer it's a wonderful museum piece
actually i have to say that um and so
you'll find it in a lot of computer
museums et cetera et cetera you also
find it
in movies i think it was in jurassic
park among others exactly
what it was doing there is not
completely clear but um it was flashing
its lights
and and having a good time so to speak i
mean i have to say in a footnote to
history
um a long-time employee at our company
um ended up
who uh somehow getting a portion of a
connection machine computer
um that was given to him by
a u.s national lab that really wanted to
get rid of it
and basically said if you'll just take
this away
you can have it and so he had it for a
long time in his garage and i believe it
is now
at our offices in illinois i haven't
seen it there
but some so i believe we we have a a
piece i don't know what it is a quarter
of a connection machine um i'm afraid
probably not i don't know whether it's
alive enough to have its lights flash
it's a good question
um i haven't seen it in in the flesh
because i uh
because there's been a pandemic in
things and i haven't been there and uh
i should check it out but any case but
back to back to the company
so so um let's see what what
um oh gosh uh it's a bit uh
sorry this is uh this is what happens
when memories that are 35 years old or
something
they they tend to come back in a bit of
a jumble but um
uh about thinking machines so so you
know
the original development was all about
making this this black cube computer
that would have
well there was a small version with uh
16 000 processors and a big version with
65 000 processors
i think it was a the basic price point
was a million dollars per computer
and um the idea was to make this sort of
the to implement marvin's theory about
ai
and make this kind of um uh this
connection machine
ai computer that wasn't a great business
strategy
i mean it didn't take a lot of effort to
point out that
you know who is going to be the single
user ai researcher
who is going going to be given this
million dollar thing to use
how is that going to work uh shell was
very keen that the company really
sell to companies that would have a a
practical sort of industrial use for the
for the computer
and um i think there were um some
finance companies i think
uh uh if i remember maybe american
express maybe dow jones
they were early customers um there was
clearly a
a um an opportunity at national labs um
places like los alamos livermore uh
places like that
which um we're interested in in having
the fastest computers
um both as a way of researching
computers but also they had a very
specific use case for those fast
computers
which was um particularly at that time
which was
uh doing simulations of physical
processes
and particularly nuclear explosions um
again i'm i'm segueing slightly into a
slightly different topic but one of the
things that happened at that time
was the test ban nuclear test ban and
you know it had been the case when you
were trying to figure out if you could
make a
nuclear weapon that worked you just
tested it and you either tested it by
digging a hole in the ground and
sticking your nuclear weapon
um in in in the ground and and blowing
it up and then
you'd have this all these pictures of
the sort of ground caving in on top
as things have been vaporized underneath
or something or
in earlier years in the 1950s
particularly uh
you know there were nuclear tests uh in
the atmosphere particularly in the
pacific and so on
um making a bit of a mess um i mean it's
sort of a remarkable thing that the
the the nuclear tests in the pacific uh
caused when i was a kid and you learned
about hydrogen
you know you learned hydrogen has three
isotopes that are that are
sort of reasonably stable you know the
the one proton
one zero neutrons um the the
deuterium where there's a proton and one
neutron and tritium
where there's a proton and two neutrons
well tritium was not stable it's
radioactive with a half-life of
maybe what is it 17 years or something
like that um
and you know i i kind of one learnt
the um the abundance of tritium in in
in hydrogen which was mostly based on
abundance in seawater and so
on as a way it's a proxy for sort of the
general abundance of
of tritium was a number well turns out
that number is now different
why is the number now different it's
different because when i was a kid in
the 1960s
the um the tritium there was a bunch of
tritium that existed in the world
from nuclear explosions that had
happened in the pacific
and turns out water mixes very quickly
on the earth
and so the tritium spread to water all
over the earth and it affects the
isotopic abundance
anyway back in the in the early 1980s
even
underground testing of nuclear weapons
had been banned and so
there was the question how would one
ever know what was going to happen if i
wanted to change the design of a nuclear
weapon or whatever else however know it
would work well the answer is
you had to do a computer simulation of
it that was a hard thing to do
and people uh people tried very hard to
validate
that the simulations that they did would
actually work and it required sort of
super computers and things to be able to
do those simulations
one of the important validations was
supernova explosions
because that was sort of the same
physics of nuclear processes going on
and uh so there was a sort of a big
trauma for a long time
that um uh supernova explosions if you
calculated them
using the same general kind of code that
was used to study nuclear weapons
that gosh supernovas shouldn't happen
stars shouldn't explode
it's a bit of a problem it turned out
many years later i think
i've heard this story in various
variants so i'm not i can't can't say it
from completely
first-hand experience but my impression
is that what
actually happened was that some neutrino
opacity data cards
have been mistyped so it's a big
complicated simulation
and turned out the amount of the rate at
which energy could be lost from a star
by neutrino emission
um was was wrong and that was because
some data card had been mistyped and
that
turned into this whole supernova can't
explode thing but in any case
at the time you know big focus on
supercomputers partly for nuclear
weapons simulation
um and uh so that was sort of a good
potential
market for the connection machine and
thinking machines
they were not so keen on that market not
because they were opposed to the defense
establishment in fact they had a lot of
close connections to the defense
establishment um
but uh because i think they were really
interested to see sort of
truly commercial scalable applications
rather than something which will be
limited to a small number of government
labs
but in any case the government labs were
a good market for them
so something that happened that i was
deeply involved in
i tried to figure out so what was the
connection machine actually good for i
actually recently found my
my notes about sort of scientific
computing with the connection machine
which i
recently put up on the web um and uh
uh but one of the things that was sort
of a big big application error for
supercomputers was fluid dynamics
was computing the motion of fluids
whether air or water or something else
according to the equations of
hydrodynamics and so on
so i've been working a lot on cellular
automata discrete systems very simple
programs but they did
and so one of the things that um uh
i sort of realized was gosh you could
use this connection machine computer was
a really good cellular automaton
computer
even if that wasn't making use of its
whole connection connect this to that
everywhere
type capability was really good as a
cellular automaton computer so let's use
it
to do fluid dynamics oh and by the way
can i invent a scheme for fluid dynamics
that would make use of cellular
automatic
and uh turned out that was uh started a
whole uh
area of fluid dynamics simulation where
instead of having sort of a
starting from the the continuum
equations and breaking them down to
something a computer can deal with
you start from kind of these idealized
discrete molecules
and then kind of build up to something
which simulates the fluid
and and that idea actually interestingly
has reappeared
in what we're doing in our fundamental
theory of physics now and in fact um
uh jonathan gorod who's been working on
that project is
is even even as we speak working very
hard
on being able to have a new scheme for
doing numerical relativity
and computing black hole mergers and all
those kinds of things
using a method that is not based on
cellular automata it's based on these
hypography writing systems that we're
doing right now
but it's using the same idea as this
thing that i originally invented
for as a way to find something useful
for the connection machine computer to
do
so it's one of those cases where sort of
technology development drove a piece of
basic science
um i also i've been working actually
worked on rule 30
and my kind of randomness generation
mechanism
when when i was working um uh a summer
that i was working i think summer of
1984 maybe 1985
um i worked on that and that was the
case where again i was able to use the
connection machine computer
to to do this very large scale
calculation of of the rule 30 cellular
automaton
and try and validate the randomness that
rule 30 seem to be generating
um i remember one of the things i think
i have it somewhere this
this i was able to make this giant print
out of rule 30 um
that was printed out on the same kind of
on the same printer that um
the hardware designers that thinking
machines use to print um
uh circuit boards and and so on and uh
and chip designs and such like
um but anyway i had a it was a nice kind
of visual which unfortunately i don't
think anybody took a picture of it would
have been a good
one of these good historical pictures i
suppose um where
they had this giant print out of rule 30
unrolled on the floor at thinking
machines
and uh all kinds of people including
myself and dick feinman were kind of
crawling over this thing
with meter rules trying to measure
various properties of this um
of this particular thing and dick fimen
had this whole argument about why
some particular angle some particular
thing should be 0.25
and it turned out upon upon more
detailed measurement it turns out to be
0.2481 but 0.25 is a good approximation
but we didn't understand why it wouldn't
be exactly 0.25 based on
based on that calculation but i remember
in one of the things which for me is a
kind of a an interesting story i mean uh
after that sort of adventure of of the
meter rules and rule 30 and so on
um uh dick clement have been have been
looking at this
rule 30 thing of mine and and was like
you know
it's uh at first he was like i you know
i can't believe a system
uh rule that's this simple can produce
this much complexity
and eventually he's like okay okay i
agree it does do that there's no
kind of way to sort of crack it and find
out that it's actually simpler than that
but
but right at that moment when we were
sort of studying this big print out he
kind of takes me aside and says
look i just want to know one thing you
know how did you know that this
particular simple rule was going to
produce all this
randomness and complicated behavior and
i was like well i didn't
i just did a bunch of simulations and
you know i did these experiments
and this is one of the things i found
and so he says
ah i feel much better you know i thought
you actually had some intuition that
would tell you
uh that this is how it had to work i
said no no it's just experiments
just an empirical science kind of thing
okay he's much much happier with that
because his intuition like mine didn't
encompass this kind of phenomenon
it was very surprising and uh you know i
think he was uh
you know dick climber was always a
person who was very keen on
kind of um uh sort of adding intuition
into physics i mean he tended to work in
sort of the inverse of ways
that that some people including myself
probably tend to work
which is he was a calculator first an
intuition later
kind of person so he was very good at
calculation he was very good at actually
working things out usually using not
terribly high-tech mathematics
he usually used sort of 19th century
mathematics kind of
calculus plus plus type mathematics um
but he was very good at that and you
know he would do these long calculations
and the big surprise for me is he would
get the right answer
and um you know i think to get the right
answer you have to know well i can
approximate this i can drop that
i need to you know if this isn't coming
out right i must have made a sign error
somewhere etcetera etcetera etcetera you
get the right answer
but he thought that was trivial getting
the right answer from these calculations
so he would take the result of the
calculation and he would try and think
is there an intuitive way to see why
it's obvious that this will be the
answer from the calculation
then he would eventually usually come up
with this amazing
sort of intuition based explanation of
why it had to be that way
and then he wasn't very impressed with
the fact that he'd done this big
calculation got the right answer
he'd throw that away and he'd just tell
people well the answer is this because
and then he'd explain this piece of
intuition
and so it was kind of funny because
people would
you know i would sometimes know about
what the what the back room calculations
were
it's like people would be like oh that's
very impressive piece of intuition
and then they would try and work out how
would we calculate that because we don't
have this kind of intuition how would we
calculate that and sometimes it took
years for people to try and reverse
engineer
what calculation would give you the same
result as this intuition
but dick fireman already had had done
the calculation
he just didn't tell anybody about it and
i don't think he did that
to be kind of a better showman i think
he did that because as is often the case
you know the calculations came easily to
him and so he didn't think they were
anything remarkable
the intuition card for everybody it was
hard for him too
and so that was much more something he
felt you know proud of and impressed by
rather than just oh it's just a
calculation kind of thing
anyway thank you machines well so
uh you know i would always be jumping up
and down about how
you know the business strategy of the
company wasn't the right thing etc etc
etc
and and dick feinman would always say
you know
we we often timed our visits there to
coincide he would say
let's just hide away and do physics
let's you know leave these guys to run
their business we don't know anything
about running businesses
you know let them run their business
we'll just hide away and do physics
and i was like but it's going to fail
you know it's it's you can't do that
it's it's you know you've got to think
about
you know what the market is what um you
know how to actually make a thing where
the product you're selling
is actually something people want to buy
and so on but
um anyway it's um
uh i think uh dick feinman's experience
with sort of
business and and business management and
so on hadn't been particularly
positive i mean the two groups that he
had most interacted with
were university administrators and
publishing companies
and he was very down on both of those
groups and
and probably those haven't attracted the
the sort of the most at least you know
these
industries go up and down but but um uh
i think particularly at that time they
weren't attracting the sort of perhaps
the best and the brightest in terms of
of terms of strategic business thinking
more people who were
you know running an organization that
already existed and so on
um and so i i remember uh dick finally
wrote a book called qed
about quantum electrodynamics and um i
remember
him just railing on and on to me about
these publishers they're so stupid
they're putting this
cover picture on this book and it's
nothing to do with quantum
electrodynamics
i keep on telling them you know it was a
picture of some um
uh newton's fringes in in
some oil type thing and he's like this
doesn't need quantum electron dynamics
this is just classical optics
it's irrelevant they don't understand et
cetera et cetera et cetera
um but uh in any case
the um uh so so that was kind of the the
background to that
i think also you know one of the early
investors and thinking machines had been
um
uh uh bill william pally
who was yeah
william pally or am i mistaking that
with the early natural theology person
um any case uh the person who is the the
relevant person in this case is the
founder of cbs
uh television network um who was a
relative of of cheryl handlers actually
um the uh anyway he was one of the early
investors in thinking machines
corporation
and i think um one of the claims that
one of the things
he said was you know look i'm going to
invest in this company
and if this company has a one in a
million chance of inventing the
transistor of artificial intelligence
this is a huge win i have to say the
cynical me
said when i when i heard that i said i
wonder how long it will be
before you know he's kind of banging his
fist on the table saying
where's the revenue i think the answer
was
well maybe a couple of years um but in
any case
the um uh i think that um
uh such such as the way of of um kind of
uh um i don't know an
investment or something i mean i think
it's it's thinking machines was intended
as a
as a you know as a as a serious
commercial enterprise
um in the end uh well one of the
problems that they had was
it's sort of an interesting product
design issue
was you know was their machine a generic
supercomputer
or was it this special wacky thing
that had was this experiment in making a
massive number of
processors that worked in a way that was
very different from other computers
the primary competitors at the time were
were cray computers
crazy supercomputers and craig computers
basically were running fortran programs
they were taking floating point numbers
they were
crunching them they had array arithmetic
they had all kinds of things like that
and the connection machine didn't have
any of that it just had processors that
that uh operated with four bits at a
time
didn't have any notion of real numbers
it didn't have any notion of floating
point
all these kinds of things so it was you
know it was great for cellular automata
it was terrible for for standard
floating point arithmetic
and for example in doing fluid dynamics
there was this choice you could either
use my kind of method with cellular
automata
where just working up from the bits was
great or you could use the traditional
method doing numerical analysis
with the navi stokes equations in which
case you had to work with floating point
numbers
you had to work kind of down from the
continuum so
it was in a sense it was uh and
particularly was one marketing guy
uh named jim bailey who was some uh i
thinking machines who kind of got this
point very clearly
it's like if cellular automata wins then
you know in fluid dynamics then the
connection machine wins
if navier stokes wins then cray wins
and so it was kind of a science and
technology
kind of going hand in hand and quite a
bit of progress was made
but um the problem was when it came to
to you know being out in the field
actually selling a machine you know
if you're a salesperson for a 10 million
dollar supercomputer for example you
might sell one every few years
and um you know you want to kind of have
the best shot and it got very
complicated
to do the selling of this machine where
the competitor was
was the cray computer and it was like
well where's your fortran benchmark
connection machine well we don't have a
fortran benchmark why don't you have a
fortran benchmark
are you slower than cray or what what's
the story and so
that was a big confusion and i think the
wrong decision was made i think the
the correct decision which i certainly
pushed very hard was
you know this is a different data point
in the world of computers
it's relevant for people who care about
the future it's not relevant for people
who just want to make a continuous
gradation from the past but um
unfortunately sort of market forces and
the sort of sales operation and so on
ended up with oh let's add a floating
point unit let's make something that's
kind of a bit like a cray
that was not a good idea and i think in
the end the company failed and it was
was most of its pieces were sold to some
microsystems
in the end which in which in turn
eventually got sold to oracle
um but uh uh in any case the
i suppose one other piece of the whole
uh story
uh it's a long and shaggy story isn't it
i mean this is what happens after
i've interacted with this company for
quite a number of years um
another piece was the design of
languages so
the connection machine computer uh sort
of the primary
sort of control computers were list
machines which was kind of interesting
and um so there was a a variant of lisp
that was intended to um uh run on this
parallel computer i have to say i never
really used this much
it was used a bunch to do calculations
sort of for me
but i should have gotten my hands more
you know my fingers more on the keyboard
there of really using it because i
really didn't um and it was it was a
little bit of a babysitting required
kind of thing and you had to
you had to actually you know be in at
the level of
understanding the details of the
hardware to really write these programs
actually
one of the favorite things which i don't
think i unfortunately kept
um which which happened which was just
just a classic
was they're doing these fluid dynamic
simulations on the connection machine
computer
you know they're they're literal
calculations where there are molecules
that are represented by
different processors on the computer and
so on one of the processors
actually physically blew up exploded
whatever
failed green smoke came out of it um
what one saw on the list machine that
was sort of watching that simulation was
this giant fluid velocity right there at
that region
in the fluid because there was actually
a mapping between the physical
location of parts of the fluid and
physical processes on the connection
machine so
explosion in processor means giant you
know
uh fast fluid flow um there in the
in the um uh in the picture from from
the machine
but anyway so one of the things that i
worked on was was developing
uh an extension to see for the
connection machine
c-star was the name i gave it um which
was intended to be a kind of uh
extension to see that would be good for
a parallel computer
and i was very proud of the fact that it
was a very minimal design
in the end there was just a single new
keyword
which was the word parallel and so in c
you know you can declare something like
int
x means uh a a variable x of type
integer
or in star x a variable
that is a pointer to an integer and so
the idea was there will be a parallel
um int x which meant there was going to
be an instance of x in every processor
of the connection machine and and then
the idea was that
star x which would take the address
of something which stored an integer
star x that indirection operation
would be the thing that actually caused
it to move data from one processor to
another
so if x was a pointer to an integer it
might be a pointer that represented
a location on different um oh as you
know
this this keyword uh parallel was what i
guess
in um in c will be called a storage
class so i don't know whether it exists
in modern versions of c but it used to
be the case
that you could declare variables as
being like
register int blah blah blah which meant
hint to the compiler this variable is
going to be used a lot
to try and put it in a register right on
the cpu um
so that was a kind of a storage class
declaration so the idea was to add a
parallel storage cost declaration
that would represent put it in all the
different processes of the of the
connection machine
unfortunately the implementation of sea
star got all
you know tangled up and it it rapidly
became this vastly more complicated
thing i don't know whether it was ever
fully implemented
at all but i was i was sad because it
was a very beautifully minimal design
and i think was one of these cases where
it just looked too simple people
couldn't believe that something that
simple would work
but i think it would would have done
actually at the time
i got quite interested in the problem of
of how would you really think about
doing
computation and parallel and and um
doing lots of operations where you
didn't necessarily know when the
operations would occur
and i started thinking about using graph
based languages doing graph rewriting
as a way to represent uh kind of
parallel computations that was in the
mid 1980s
well ironically enough graph rewriting
is exactly the foundation
of what we've been doing in our
fundamental theory of physics and by the
way
from what i've learned from the
fundamental theory of physics i've now
realized that finally i think i'm
beginning to understand
how one can actually think about doing
parallel computation using graph
rewriting
using ideas that i don't feel so bad
because they're ideas
i really profoundly didn't have in the
1980s their ideas that come from
understanding
this correspondence between graph
rewriting and physics
and ideas about kind of programming in
reference frames and
things that one gets from the general
theory of relativity
in physics that one can now convert into
things about graphs
and so i don't feel as bad that i didn't
figure that out in the 1980s
but that was something that i had been
thinking about at that time
when thinking machines finally kind of
self-destructed
when was that must have been late 80s
early 90s
it was kind of a sad thing to see i
wasn't i was not really involved at all
at that time
um the uh it had just collected a
wonderful group of people
who kind of scattered to different
places and have had a lot of different
interesting careers
um the actual company i think could have
been saved i believe i don't know the
innards of it and probably enough detail
to say for sure but i think
i think at the end people just sort of
gave up um i think that there'd been
this push into doing something that was
very
unique and innovative and there was a
sort of push back from the market just
do something generic
um you know there was a certain tension
between
you know the the uh cheryl used to have
this the sign up um
that was a quote from danny that was
something like you know
our mission is to make a computer that
can be proud of us
and that that's that's amusing but in
the end
you know there's a certain drumbeat of
you have to actually sell computers to
customers
i do also another thing that has to be
said in terms of kind of the
the the the atmosphere of innovation i
would say was very good at thinking
machines
uh you know cheryl um had this kind of
idea that in addition to getting
sort of the best people she wanted sort
of the best office space
and she had a very uh very interior
designed
you know walls painted all different
colors and sometimes a little bit
impractical of not having them be
be a rectilinear you know wall assembly
so to speak and that's always difficult
to
to deal with but but um uh she um
she was very big on kind of the um uh
the kind of um
providing an interesting and innovative
environment both in terms of people and
in terms of the physical environment
one of the things that people used to
kind of
make fun of her about was when they
first shipped
connection machine computers she had
this whole team of people gift wrap
i'm not sure if it was the whole
computer if it was just the
documentation
um for delivery to customers i always
thought that was cute um
other people thought that was cheryl
being crazy but um
i thought that was a it was a good way
to to present
kind of the um uh the the kind of the
the
the fact of being proud of the computer
one had made even if the computer
couldn't yet be proud of one back
all right very long answer to that
question let me let me keep going here
um
uh
oh richard is commenting that c and c
plus
have a parallel for loop parallelization
but there's nothing for distributed
variable storage okay
interesting okay so we're still we're
still not at that level of modernness
uh uh
let's see a few other comments here
humanities is asking about combinator
graph reduction machines
um i believe made by people like david
turner
um i'm aware of these actually a friend
of mine from high school
named philip gladstone uh when he was in
cambridge made
uh was involved in making one of those
machines um
i think it's a based on microcode and so
on um i
i've never touched one with my own
fingers so to speak um but yes i'm aware
of their existence
um david here is asking have i read
surely you're joking mr feynman
and what do you care what other people
think and too robust
i have to admit i have not read these
books i have the theory that i've heard
every story in them uh sometimes in
multiple variants
um and
so i'm i'm i'm kind of i i'm gonna stick
with the versions of the stories that i
remember so to speak
um and not be spoiled by by ralph
leighton's
rendering of them in the books but i
think uh
the um
it was kind of interesting to see
you know dick feynman like telling
stories about things
i guess i do too um and uh
sometimes and i think one of the things
to um
uh uh you know somehow
stories that climber would tell would
often be the same stories and i think
it's kind of a lesson for those of us
who tell stories it's like
like make sure you know the facts very
accurately
and and i you know i've kept good
archives so when i when i consult those
i'm always kind of like
well i had that more or less right but
there's a detail i didn't quite have
right
um and the detail doesn't usually matter
to the
the arc of the story but uh if you're
doing history
those things can matter um i think that
uh
um uh yeah i i think um
um i do think sometimes the title what
do you care what other people think
is a slightly amusing title for dick
pimen because because he did care a bit
what other people think
i mean he wasn't um you know he he felt
an obligation to his audiences for
example when he would give talks
you know i remember one time you know he
was giving some talk and he was like i'm
worrying about this talk
and i'm like why are you worrying about
this talk and he's like
because people think i give great talks
so
that means that the you know the
threshold is raised
but um uh yeah i don't know um
i mean that the tuva story is also a
story of carl carl feynman
um and i do remember hearing all about
tuva
uh long before the kind of uh the the
expedition to tuva or whatever
eventually happened with with tuva i
mean i think it was one of these
let's pick the most obscure place in the
world and figure out a way to it i i
have to say that reminds me
of a thing that um i had going for a
while with danny hillis
um which was a oh a crazy idea of mine
back in the days when
when um uh uh you know
well back in the days when you could
just go to an airport and go get on a
plane there used to be this
um when i lived in princeton back in the
early 80s
there was a an airline called people
express which was one of the early
discount airlines
and it had the feature that you could
like just go to the airport get on the
plane
you know you're going to wherever and go
you know pay for your ticket on the
plane and it's kind of like a like a
bus more like a bus type thing so i had
this
idea a few times just as a as a weird
thing to do
in my in my last time i took a vacation
which was sometime in the early 1980s
um it's like uh just go to the airport
and go to the first
whatever the first place that's listed
on the departures for people express go
get on that plane and go to wherever
and so i did that a few times kind of
interesting um uh
you know younger crazier time but um
uh so i kind of had this thing that i
had been thinking about doing with danny
where we'd pick a random
coordinates random uh you know random
coordinates on the surface of the earth
and it was sort of a competition whoever
could get to
that place first kind of wins the game
and you know you just pick anywhere on
the earth well we never implemented this
i thought it would be an amusing thing i
suppose it's a little bit like the
modern geocaching idea or something but
um uh you know probably just as well we
didn't implement it because those places
if they'd been
uh might have been in some some uh
awkward dangerous difficult
um parts of the world and probably just
as well we never never tried doing it
um let's see
uh
right grateful tomato comments that
nowadays every modern computer has a
connection machine in the form of a gpu
yeah kind of although although gpus are
very much
um you know operating
uh kind of in lockstep there's you know
a single instruction multiple data
type things where you say this is a
vector i'm going to do this to it
rather than this idea which was sort of
the core idea of the connection machine
which was uh from any place to any place
uh you know have this whole big shuffle
around of all this data
um that was the kind of um um
uh that was the kind of idea
let's see um
okay let's see
uh parmese comments that of of course i
know the person yes i i consider
brewster kelly a good friend the person
who started the internet archive
uh he he has had an interesting kind of
trajectory because he was at thinking
machines after he was at mit
and then um at thinking machines he
developed this thing called wastes
wais which was
some kind of a an early
uh sort of web-like thing
um the uh um
and uh let's see he ended up selling
waste to i think aol
actually i have to tell another thinking
machine story so thinking machines did
all kinds of research
that wasn't specifically around it sort
of sort of supercomputer thing
one of the pieces of research it did was
um into
early travel directions
so the idea was today you know gps's
all that kind of thing it can tell you
how to go from here to there
okay so back in the day thinking
machines this is probably 1984
wanted to build a thing like that so
they had a street map
and they had been interested in routing
algorithms algorithms
where you could uh do this sort of
computation which could be done rather
nicely in parallel
of how you route through the graph of
streets to get from here to there
okay so what were you going to do back
in 1984 to have people in practice
use street routing like that okay they
had the following idea
take pay phones okay nobody knows what a
pay phone is anymore
used to be the case that it was a common
thing to like you you didn't have cell
phones right
so if you were in some random place and
you wanted to make a phone call you
would go find a pay phone pick it up and
put money in it or or use your telephone
credit card or something like that
and make a call okay so
i guess at that time there was
uh yeah caller id was just coming in
these ani
data the a i data that represents the
the the incoming call information was
just coming in at that time
so you could get the incoming call
information what was the number of the
cell phone you were calling from
so what they did was they got for the
boston area they got a directory of all
the
i said cell phone i meant pay phone what
was the the
so what was what were all the pay phones
in the boston area
what were their physical locations and
what were their phone numbers
and so then the idea was to navigate you
would go
and you would say i'm lost so then you
would stop at a pay phone you pick up
the pay phone
you'd call the system and the system
would know where you were
because it could see the caller id
information
from this pay phone and then it would
figure out where you were on the map and
then had a voice synthesizer it was
using a thing called the deck talk
which was an early voice synthesizer it
was a kind of a weird product built by
digital equipment corporation
it's kind of this box about about um oh
about
so big or something of maybe a foot long
or something i used to have one of these
actually i'm not sure what happened to
my
my deck talk but the deck talk was um
uh was a voice synthesizer
so you would feed in it was like a like
a printer
you would kind of feed it or like a um
more like a teletype you would you know
a terminal
you would feed it text and it would say
the text it had maybe three voices or
something
it was a piece of hardware basically
that did that so they'd connected a deck
talk to the phone
so you would from the pay phone you
would you would uh
uh call into this this number that you
you remembered that was there sort of uh
um direction uh information
number it would know where you were from
the pay phone caller id
and then it would figure out you know
quickly what was the right route to
where you were trying to get to
and then it would um uh it would read
you back the directions
okay so they wanted to test this they
had a version of this they wanted to
test it
so i said sure i'm an out of town person
and uh you know i'll test this thing
okay
so there i was it was actually one of
the big mistakes was i should have had a
a co-pilot who actually knew the area at
least a bit
and i should have also had a paper map
but anyway i said i'm going to test this
okay so i'm we there's some destination
was picked
and i'm like driving around and some i
forget is probably my own car
i had um uh uh up in boston
um and um uh
um so i'm driving around and i got
absolutely irreducibly lost and i was
calling
all these different you know stopping at
all these pay phones and i don't think
i'm very good at
the best of times at hearing directions
and being able to implement them
but this was the pits and it was you
know i started in probably the early
afternoon
and i remember it was getting dark and
it was you know like where the heck
am i and um i i don't actually remember
how that resolved maybe i stopped at a
gas station and bought a map
um but uh that was a so i i got to be
the the very first
human guinea pig for direction
assistance on
computers and it didn't work well with
me but i was probably a bad case
you know i'm just the person who just
follows the turn-by-turn
instructions from the gps but it was an
interesting it was it was one of
a number of very interesting initiatives
there was also a person called dave
waltz
at thinking machines who was some
involved in doing
um they were uh doing text retrieval
and um what was the idea there they had
a
uh was it a thesaurus or what was the
idea
um but anyway it was it was a kind of a
whole text retrieval play
that i think laid the groundwork for
some of the things that ended up
happening
uh with search engines later on um but
anyway brewster
did this waste thing that sort of spun
out a bit from thinking machines
then after he sold that company he did
another company called alexa internet
uh noticed the the coincidence of names
is not as much of a coincidence as you
might think
alexa internet um had the idea of giving
people a browser plug-in
um that would give them some additional
internet surfing capabilities
but it will also record what sites
people were visiting
as a way to know how many times
different sites were being visited and
that's turned into
the whole alexa ranking mechanism that
exists for websites but anyway brewster
sold that company in the end
uh to amazon um and uh i i'm pretty sure
there's a straight line i never actually
asked anybody i should have done
whether there's a straight line from the
alexa company that they bought from
brewster
and the alexa intelligent assistant that
um that they use our technology for
example for
um in uh uh in in that space
um but anyway so so then brewster
brewster sold that to amazon
and then started the internet archive uh
with
with the money he made from that um and
uh really kind of wanted to theme
himself as as the librarian of the
internet which i thought was just a
terrific
thing to do and and a terrific i i think
brewster's had a very uh
interesting and productive career and
he's kind of gone through these
these multiple stages of of different
very different kinds of things and and
very interesting things
being done at the at the internet
archive and so on
um i mean i could uh you know brewster
uh
i think it's fair to tell a few stories
about brewster um
one of the things you know he has uh the
headquarters of the internet archive is
um right near the presidio in san
francisco
um and brewster said to me one day you
know he had this logo for the internet
archive which was this kind of um
very uh establishment looking you know
pillars and
and um you know like like the kind of
icon that that
universities will often have or or
courts of law will have things like that
where it's it's the kind of the
the very classical building kind of
temple-like thing
okay so you've had this logo for a while
and then
turns out there was a building just near
the presidio
that came available for sale and the
building as brewster put it
looked just like his logo so he had to
buy this building
the building was a um a former a church
what was it
um universalist church i don't know um
some uh um some sort of
intellectually oriented church sect i
don't remember exactly which one um
but in any case the um so brewster
bought a church and that's the
headquarters of the internet archive
and so the the kind of the biggest room
he has there
is this um uh this this whole thing with
a bunch of pews and so on in it and with
an organ i think even at the back
and um uh so what did brewster put in
the pews
he's put um these uh paper mache models
of people who have been as long-term
employees and it's kind
of brewster's some version of the xi'an
uh terracotta warriors and it's really
quite a strange thing to see
and um i i've i was lost there maybe
18 months a couple of years ago um i uh
insisted on taking a picture of brewster
sitting with his paper mache model
in the pews in his um in his uh
uh church and actually what's kind of
particularly interesting about that sort
of big sort of church
room is that at the back of it are these
things with flashing lights actually
that um are pieces of the internet
archive
and brewster's done this kind of
surprising thing of being able to have
air-cooled
very very simple cooling mechanisms for
um
uh for his uh uh for his um
uh systems and he's got you know the
petabytes of data
and some of them are right at the back
of this big room sort of being cooled by
just the the volume of air in the room
um i think uh brewster's ended up with
some interesting issues they've been
digitizing books i i guess he's got now
got two or three million books
that are sitting in containers in the
port of san francisco last i knew
um that are you know a very big supply
of uh
mostly out of copyright books um and
bruce has been thinking about
interesting plans for what to do with a
few million books
um given that they've mostly been
digitalized by now um
they've they've developed to uh actually
i
i um uh made use of a bunch of brewster
early brewster ideas because i
wanted to digitize a bunch of documents
that i have and so brewster was like
don't don't use a scanner just use a
camera
just you know you just press the button
on a camera high resolution camera
works much better than the scanner once
you built the kind of rig to look have
the camera look down on the
on the on the document and so on and i
think we maybe suggested a few things
that had to do with how to
arrange for white balance and so on and
photograph additional things in the
frame
so that you can then do do subsequent
correction of colors and
and things like that but anyway um
that's uh boy i can i can get into
an infinite number of of uh uh weird and
and um
um um funky stories
uh a question from grateful tomato here
um um
the uh um
[Music]
about uh what were the actual use cases
of the interconnections in the
connection machine computer
good question they were not as useful as
you would think
um so there were some things with uh
with um
uh routing and uh
making and graph theoretical algorithms
where you could make use of these
you know you essentially represent the
graph in the connections
um there were also things where there
were a pattern
of data flow that wasn't like in a
cellular automaton where you just got
local data flowing
to neighboring nodes there were things
like doing fast fourier transforms where
you have this kind of butterfly
arrangement
of of data being uh the shuffle
shuffle network um kind of perfect
shuffle like with cards
network that is the thing that's that's
good for fast fourier transforms
and then there were some other cases i
mean i think
things like the um the problem of of of
routing through roads and so on i think
that can be done
in a way that that works using that kind
of parallel system
i mean i don't think that many
algorithms perhaps have been studied
in as much detail as they could have
been in the context of such an
architecture because it isn't
it hasn't become a standard architecture
so people are much more what can you do
with vectors and arrays and so on
then what can you do with this very fast
arbitrary connection kind of network
um and i think you know this problem of
the delivery
times is a serious problem and it's
known that for example i
i think um i think les valiant had
proved some theorem
that said that um uh if every piece of
data
gets routed to a random location and
then to where it's finally going
it will never get gummed up but
then you're wasting all the time getting
it to the random location before you get
it
to the final location and and many of
these issues about sort of routing and
how you do
i mean these issues have come up in many
kind of computer networking settings
but this is a much more extreme version
of them than is than is typical for for
typical computer networks i mean i think
the same thing um um
came up again recently uh a uh a kind of
a blockchain-like
initiative called nkn which i like
because it kind of rhymes with nks it
stands for
new kind of network that kind of uh you
know alliterates with new kind of
science and unintentionally so
um that's a that's a sort of a way of of
routing messages
through kind of an overlay on top of the
internet uh where it's sort of um
uh the routing channels are defined by
people getting cryptocurrency for
routing through their part of the
network and
and so on but they have some of the same
kinds of issues
that um of delivery that um i had seen
with
with the connection machine although i
think distributed hash tables and things
like that have a different kind of
solution to these
these approaches well
i should um uh
i should probably wrap up because i
think i'm i'm um
um
um about
to run into the time when i'm supposed
to go and do
a a piece of my my day job um
i noticed some questions here about um
the path of mechanics from newton
through dellumber to lagrange i can i
could talk about that another time
um and uh yeah we seem to have talked a
lot about um
about thinking machines corporation and
the connection machine computer
it's a it's a fine historical topic um
i think uh um
[Music]
probably should um leave it there
so thanks very much and and our schedule
is um
uh i will be doing another one of these
history of science and technology q as
uh plan is two weeks from today next
week at this time
um i'll talk about business and
innovation
and um then i guess on friday
i'm doing a
q a general q a about science and
technology for kids and others
so thanks for joining me here and